[Musique]
un château fort au coeur de la puisaye
guideront c'est un chantier qui avance
tous les jours week-ends compris du
printemps à l'automne une quinzaine de
métiers tous scrupuleusement pratiquer
avec les méthodes et outils début du
xiiie siècle guédelon une aventure hors
norme qu'on rejoint clair par tran décor
nicolas charpentier et théophile masson
je suis venu à guédelon quand j'étais
plus petit je devais avoir 10 11 ans
donc j'ai taillé ma première pierre à
agay l'on à ce moment là aux ateliers de
taille de pierre
il est toujours ça a dû sûrement resté
dans un coin de ma tête j'ai découvert
la première fois le château c'était le
jour de mon entretien d'embauché
voilà donc du coup bas il ya un effet
évidemment
fascinant c'est ça sert on est bouche
bée les yeux écarquillés ya un effet
whaou
participer à la construction d'un
château forcément c'est pas tout le
monde ne fait pas ça les gens sont
intéressés les gens qui travaillent
aussi que c'est une équipe qui
fonctionne bien
depuis quelques semaines la carrière de
grès ferrugineux situé à quelques
kilomètres de saint fargeau en puisaye
résonne au son des massais des débuts
l'histoire commence voilà 24 en
1997 quelques pionniers se lance inspiré
par le propriétaire du château de saint
fargeau
c'est une véritable passion et puis le
construire pourquoi le construis pas
n'importe comment mais en utilisant les
techniques des premiers compagnons
bâtisseurs parce que la première
question que se posent tous les gens qui
rentrent dans un château dans une
cathédrale c'est mais comment ont-ils
fait pour faire ça comment ont-ils fait
ça l'aube du xxième siècle ça répond à
une question essentielle
à l'époque à la place du château un trou
béant dans les bois
un an plus tard guédelon commence déjà à
prendre forme
n'a trouvé site complètement incroyable
sur ce site on a les réserves en eau les
réserves en bois les réserves en pierre
les différents sable pour les mortiers
les réserves en terre pour l'épauler
tuiles et briques
bientôt le chantier double ses effectifs
une quarantaine de personnes qui peu à
peu re découvre les techniques oubliées
ya plein de choses qu'on fait avec des
méthodes modernes avec des engins
électriques avec des machines outils
qu'on est obligé de refaire à la main et
pour ça il a fallu trouver des artisans
qui nous ont appris les gestes on
descend très nettement un enfant dans
les bras dans les mains
des deux l'ont séduit 3 ans après ses
débuts grâce aux entrées des visiteurs
le chantier s'autofinance déjà il va
rapidement devenir le 2e site payant le
plus fréquenté de bourgogne juste
derrière les hospices de beaune
[Musique]
du moyen-âge c'est intéressant en
discussions avec les deux mêmes j'adore
j'adore ça et vous comment vous trouvez
ici
comme une vache dans un pré
dix ans après le coup d'envoi la
progression des travaux et spectaculaire
de voûte a croisées d'ogives sont
terminées guédelon est bel et bien sorti
de terre
on en est là aujourd'hui
on est juste avant la pause des appuis
de fenêtres voiliers et le but c'est de
pouvoir poser les fenêtres et terminer
la façade
aujourd'hui le logis seigneurial est
terminée tout comme la tour de la
chapelle le plus gros des remparts et
une partie du donjon
florian le maître d'oeuvre dirige
toujours les travaux 24 ans d'une vie
consacrée à guédelon le château allez on
va le dire comme ça est un repère
temporel
les familles viennent avec leurs enfants
et parfois avec les photos des enfants
qui vont pris devant le château
quelques années auparavant le château
est une toise qui permettent tout
simplement de se repérer dans le temps
et à l'heure où effectivement dans ces
années de début de xxième siècle
d'incertitude où on sait pas très bien
et ben voilà ce petit château de
guédelon quelque part dans l'yonne c'est
un lieu d'énergie un lieu d'imagination
et un repère qui nous fait vivre un
temps différent un temps long un tank et
du sens
il faudra dix ont encore pour tout
terminer alors au travail demain nous
retrouverons clair
nicolas
et théophile à l' ouvrage